welcome to this video playing drain you
sooner Burke Hanson that could good
score against him he's got a huge rating
edge but I fair pretty well against him
three wins two losses yeah those of you
who watch the videos you know let's say
continue streaming me going to recognize
that lost almost 100 rating points since
the video before that and this is simply
due to the fact that I had a live stream
in between where got completely killed
yeah you might have seen that live
stream em itself yeah it is not a yeah
the videos are here are produced before
hand so it is really am not a not a
perfect time line let's say this sir
live stream has been on my channel quite
some time before this is going to be
released so let's see we got a king's
indian classical and I'm kind of on my
own here I only know that this is a line
for black but I don't know any details
okay yeah I guess still see takes d5 I
don't know to simply be five in this
kind of position that's it's not clear
to me at all my night here is a bit
loose and I wonder if if i should go
Bishop b2 here or this looks can do the
bishop looks wrong they're not see for
its not possibility to be five but i'm
not sure if maybe queen bee three years
let's do that i'm really not sure about
this position how i should play this
yeah Bishop b2 looks just wrong but yeah
maybe i'll yeah i want a night on be
three actually
be three I can also try to move the
night to a three here complicated night
to a 3-wood nicely attack attack be five
I wonder how I should organize this yes
Bishop h6 this is also a move like this
should be to Bishop age six and they
don't know where I'm putting this would
like to put it on b3 Willie but it's not
so easy to do and yeah I'm not sure how
to regroup him probably i'm just
thinking here far too long it's not not
really necessary to spend that much time
a que bishop age 6 i'm just going to put
it here and claim that this is all good
on age six but well I'm still checking
b5 and i'm going to play rugae one yeah
this is what i was wanted to say this is
maybe a move this exchange sacrifice
where walk there he tries to get both
central pawns that's an interesting way
to play ok I'm going to take with this
I'm not sure how I should take but I can
cannot spend a long long time ok ok 1
i'm giving d5 away immediately and
meredith's it's probably difficult to
keep in any case but i can still want to
keep the bishop hell for the moment
let's see what he's doing you maybe can
just plain idea 6 back and try to pick
that up I have no real means to covet d5
now it's it wasn't really possible to
keep this I believe trying to trade
rooks I put probably play Roxy ATM
keep one pair of rooks on the board but
it's not not sure nothing and I'm very
sure about yet the point is that he's
covering see one here if I go Bishop see
one check that's not really really
helping me much
I have it this is really a stupid quiz
on c1 let's try to trade it rocks III is
not a big issue I believe we'd be too
and we continue 93 might be more tricky
but I can take live six and yeah so he
can take d5 now I mean after some trades
but I didn't see any means to keep the
pawn okay so he's keeping this
interestingly enough yeah as mentioned
and I room to I cannot really defended
routine wonders Knight c3 coming and so
on
really really not a good position and
very inconvenient to play trying for
Queen a seven here trying to invade them
but it's a really it's really
uncomfortable the big central pawn
murcia is quite intimidating however I'm
taking this seven how does he protected
ok like this ok I have roped in 1 i'm
not sure or Bishop g5 Bishop g5 may be
threatening a knight c6 then but anyway
this is a good developing this I hope
now it's six maybe queen bee 7 is
annoying now at least I get pieces out
somewhat and he's spending some time
knight c6 queen bee 70 can take before
that's the problem you can still take a
pee form time morning yeah maybe here it
doesn't really help to play Queen B 7 so
it's trying to win this temple yeah my
stuff is hanging here I have problems
with hanging pieces so I'm going to take
here play look see one probably trying
to play here against with the pins
they're up to six isn't helping okay
maybe I can get something back here but
i don't i don't really believe it we
were taking c6 quite a number of times
but you can just move the night I think
special going on check cannot do much
here
maybe I can get beef I've got 27 seconds
if i get b 5 maybe maybe I can try to
and try to fight check should be seven
but he will move the King probably know
that's a bedroom yeah i def to i cannot
do anything against that besides the
time exam sides a time issue yeah
complicated yeah this is rook takes III
was interesting i saw that but I wasn't
sure how to evaluate it but it seems to
be good for black yeah getting getting
the center with hindsight I probably
played this wrong here I should have
played Bishop b2 and then if he goes
here I can go here without any monkey
can still take and that is really an
issue okay then I have to protect this a
little more then maybe here trying 495
this should be about equal I don't think
I should be in trouble here why should
write be worse but and this was a this
was strong I mean I saw it but I can't
really do anything about it this is just
not good for white it's it's it's really
really uncomfortable he's getting both
pawns yeah this was also good keeping
the rook on the board of course and now
I went be should see what damage wasn't
a very happy move but whatever am I
going to do here you were just windy
five and this is better let's try to do
some invasion here Andrew k s7 is a bit
better yeah okay look at you one now I
computer gives me equal chances now but
yeah it's it's very difficult to to play
those
those kind of super precise moves this
seems better I did not really see the I
mean I wanted to go and queen bee 70
originally but this is really didn't
know where this is even stronger than
night before yeah but here the c-4 is
just killing me it just kills me I spent
too much time in the in the in the
opening phase like here this one minute
is a bit much I should just play a move
here and tell me yeah i do do nothing
fancy i mean i can play any any kind of
move even we should be three let's a
kind of hanging on to the center or so
something quickly would have would have
helped okay well thanks for watching